So I'm here with Jessica Uelmen
who's the program manager for
mobile nano-degrees here at Udacity.
Thank you so much for
talking to us today.
>> Yeah, happy to be here.
My pleasure.
>> So the first thing I wanted to
ask you was, that there's this trend
in technology that the technology
industry tends to be very male-oriented.
And there's this
perception that therefore,
any educational technology that
comes out of the technology industry
will also be oriented more towards
male style ways of learning.
So what can we do when we're designing
educational technology to make sure that
we're not preserving this trend
of it being by men for men?
>> Yeah, it's a really tough question
and a tough thing to address, but
I think it really starts with awareness,
which is great to be here and
talking about it already.
But, really scrutinizing and
looking at what's being designed,
looking at things
through a neutral lens.
Even getting feedback from women,
or from other teachers.
Education as a field,
is primarily dominated by women.
So it's kind of interesting that ed
tech then becomes more male skewed.
So I think if there's a way to sort
of start blending those worlds,
we'll get to a little more diverse pool.
>> Yeah, that makes a lot of sense,
I actually hadn't thought about
that before, but you're right that with
technology it's very male oriented, but
teaching tends to be very
female oriented And so
there's a lot of great overlap there and
a lot of chance for
collaboration as long as we
actually go out and do it.
>> Absolutely.
>> And talking to teachers I think
is something that anyone is on
the educational technology
needs to do more of anyway.
>> Yes.
>> And so
now we kind of kill two
birds with one stone.
>> Yep.
>> So, but
given that we're probably not going to
change the entire industry in the next
four months.
Of the students currently in the class,
what are some considerations they should
make when they're developing their
tools besides possibly going out and
talking to teachers?
Are there any things
they can keep in mind?
>> I think maybe just even
surveying the landscape.
I mean, there's also,
people do a lot of efforts for
putting educational technology
solutions towards women, and
a lot of times unfortunately,
that's like making it pink.
So, let's not make it pink, okay?
But, looking at those solutions,
maybe seeing what they're doing and
seeing how it might be able to
adapt to what they're building.
>> And so I think that the other thing
that comes up here is that if our
ultimate goal is to make the technology
industry itself a little bit less
male dominated, the people in this class
will go on to careers in technology.
What can they do when they're
in their future workplaces or
their current workplaces?
They can kind of try and
combat this trend a little bit.
>> Yeah, I mean, I think the main thing
and something that I always push for
is not necessarily making
a woman a commodity.
It's not a hire because she's a woman,
or it's not collaborating because she's
a woman, and
it's a very difficult thing to do.
Because if you look at,
the percentages, and
it's like wow,
there's not a whole lot of women here.
We need to hire women, but
that's not always the best solution.
And then when there are women in
the workplace in maybe leadership roles
making their impact more visible
externally and internally,
will sort of help fill that role model
role that we are always talking about.
We need more women in tech role models,
but doing so
will then hopefully inspire more
people to pursue that as a field.
>> Yeah, and I think there's a very
interesting alignment there between what
we deal with in industry, and
what we actually deal with
here in the OMS program.
That as I'm recording this, hopefully
it will change in future semesters.
The OMS program is 90% male, and
there's a tendency to think if it's 90%
male we just need to admit more women.
>> Right.
>> But that's kind of,
treating the symptom as the thing
to be treated as opposed to,
it's a symptom of some underlying issue.
And here the issue is appeal to women,
or if there are any obstacles that we're
not really considering that
apply more to women than men.
Resolving those obstacles as
opposed to just, you know,
changing admission criteria,
or something like that.
>> Right.
And I think then, also, making things
a little bit more welcoming, or
breaking down those like
a girl stereotypes.
One of the things that
always pops into my head is
I majored in electrical engineering, and
so we had to take physics classes, and
it was my sophomore year, and
we were in a physics study group.
It was me and a bunch of guys, because
that's the way it goes, and I was
helping them solve each of the problems,
and I was doing a lot of the teaching.
And one of the guys piped up and
said hey,
are we going to let the girl
teach us how it's done.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And comments like that doesn't really
make for a welcoming environment, and
it's a very benign comment, right.
It's not meant to be hurtful,
but it is uncomfortable.
So just try to be aware of
those types of comments.
>> Yeah, it plays some kind of
assumption that the assumptions really
need to be addressed.
>> Right.
>> Comment might be harmless but
what it's perpetuating is not.
>> Yes, absolutely.
>> Well, great.
Well, thank you much for
talking to us today.
>> Yeah, my pleasure.
Always happy to talk.
>> [LAUGH]